it's 1995 your word processor is open
before you press a single key you make
the most important decision of your life
what font do I use all the usual fonts
are too conventional
there were very few very casual
typefaces that you could use and keep
scrolling to stately too boring but then
it popped out of the menu
what is this fun it was so different
than everything else the way it flows is
strange
it had irregularity about it and
uniquely flawed the stems are perfectly
straight little quite wobbly this is the
font you want and in that moment you and
millions of other people click on the
button that says Comic Sans how did it
fall those loads and cherish come to
dominate the world my name is Vincent
Khmer I was a typographic engineer at
Microsoft I considered it too lotsa font
like web dings Trevor Shay and must
notably common sense so it's all my
fault
understand Comic Sans you have to
understand its creator years before his
work at Microsoft Princeton was working
on his undergrad in New York City we
went to university in the 1980s I was a
quite young rebellious fine art student
and spend a lot of time in art spaces
and I walked through the galleries of
build Soho and look at paintings and
then art work to him what separated good
art from batter was this simple
benchmark if you didn't notice them I
consider that was bad and if he did
notice it was good because least they
made you stop and look busy the shock to
you or you really liked it but if he
didn't even notice and he's walked
through it was a disaster
since it would take that philosophy to
Microsoft where he's challenged to make
a playful font for a program called
Microsoft Bob and so I looked at Batman
and The Watchmen and pretty much tried
to draw on the computer something that
looks similar to that but not copying it
so that's how Comic Sans was made I'm
just looking at comic books and comic
characters not everyone was a fan of the
fonts quirks my boss Robert Norton he
didn't really like the font and he
thought it should be a bit more
typographic and I argued and said no it
should be weird and I thought it stood
out and it wasn't boring typography
that's in a school book though the font
didn't make it to the release of
Microsoft Bob it was eventually
pre-installed on every Macintosh by 1996
I started to see it when it was in in
the wild for the creek the first one I
remember was neon sign over a score
called fun spam that's what I realize
it's going to get used any way anybody
wants to use it and that just snowballed
from there the font spread like wildfire
and ways than thinking even imagined
when I travel the world and see it in on
beach towel war memorial on bread street
sign on everything it's over exposure
even spurred a group of designers to
start an anti comic sans movement I
thought it was funny I didn't really
find it offensive after all these years
Vincent finds himself content with how
history will remember him and Comic Sans
is not one of the better pieces of art
but conceptual it's one of the best
things I've ever done it probably is the
best thing I have ever done
you
you
[Music]